if there's one thing that the harry
potter movies did exceptionally well it
was casting the right actors for the
series many substantial roles despite
the intimidating number of memorable
characters featured throughout the
original potter books the films always
consistently managed to cast talented
actors who were ultimately well suited
to their roles that wasn't just the case
with the series older figures either
many of whom were played by legendary
british stage and screen actors but also
with its younger characters emma watson
rupert grint and daniel radcliffe for
instance were all cast at young ages to
play the franchise's central trio and
the three actors grew into talented
screen performers over the course of the
series eight film installments each of
the three have gone on to have
successful acting careers outside of the
potter franchise as well however the
harry potter franchise ended up having
to recast a handful of roles across its
aid installments in fact fans may be
surprised to learn that in the case of
lavender brown the memorable character
ended up being played by a total of
three different actors though she's not
credited actor kathleen cawley
originally played lavender brown in
2002's harry potter and the chamber of
secrets two years later in 2004's harry
potter and the prisoner of azkaban the
character was played by jennifer smith
who had no lines but appeared in the
background a handful of times throughout
the film when lavender became a major
character in harry potter and the
half-blood prince though she was played
by jessie cave she went on to reprise
the role two more times in harry potter
and the deathly hallows part one and in
its 2011 follow-up deathly hallows part
two many have often wondered why the
role was played by three different
actors in the potter films but the folks
at fandom think the explanation is
pretty clear as they tell it the harry
potter and the half blood prince novel
which makes lavender a major character
for the first time was released in july
2005 after both the chamber of secrets
and prisoner of azkaban films were made
that means that at the time of their
release the teams behind those two films
didn't know that lavender would be a
major character in the future therefore
they likely just assigned the character
name to cauli and smith in the chamber
of secrets and azkaban films to help
better organize those films various
background players
screen rant theorizes that since
lavender's profile rose in the sixth
installment the producers went with a
more established actor in cave yet these
explanations haven't stopped fans from
raising concerns about the recasting
harry potter film fans know that the
lavender brown character grew in her
impact on the overall storyline in the
sixth movie when she became a love
interest for ron weasley following his
triumphant first match as the gryffindor
quidditch keeper as chants of weasley
echo in the gryffindor common room
jessie cave's lavender brown rushes in
and starts making out with ron what
those who've not read the books may not
realize is that the snogging was
described as being impossible to tell
whose hands were
whose might sound like a bit much for a
young adult franchise but some have
taken it literally as an indication that
lavender and ron have the same skin
color though it's entirely possible the
passage was meant figuratively to simply
describe how intense the cuddle session
was regardless of how one interprets
that particular line it's indisputable
that lavender was first played by two
black actors when the character had no
lines and was recast with a white actor
when the character took on a larger role
in half-blood prince of color said it's
worth pointing out the tone deafness of
recasting a role that had been played by
two black actresses with a white actress
as soon as the character is given a line
they concluded the re-casting was
especially bad since harry potter
doesn't accurately represent britain's
great diversity check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite movies
are coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Applause]
[Music]